eu trabalho tento trabalhar com projetos
que trazem o melhor das pessoas assim e
passou vento que hoje em dia o meu
projeto mais importante e é nele que tem
a porta de entrada
falando de música independente mas é
pela pressa música independente que a
gente traz as pessoas para um lugar
aonde a diversidade é importante onde a
democracia mais importante ainda é a
onde as pessoas podem se conectar e ao
mesmo tempo se retroalimentar sem
ninguém por nada simplesmente só
sentindo vendo e retribuindo entregando
também né quando a primeira vez que me
chamaram para fazer o ted
devo confessar para vocês que eu achei
que era a foto foi nossa vem falar no
ted meu deus
mas foi só o segundo disso logo em
seguida veio a ana de verdade que essa
que está aqui com a voz trêmula cheia de
medos e nervosos e borboletas no
estômago ea minha ansiedade que é uma
coisa que está sempre comigo e aí foi
nesse momento que eu falei gente mas
como assim que eu vou falar no ted não
terminei a faculdade
terminei o colegial no supletivo
repetindo segundo grau com o meu pai
assim nadal o que você está fazendo e eu
não sei nem que eu sou diretora de
filmes uma produtora eu sou uma editora
de filmes ou eu sou uma ativista
eu sou tantas outras coisas que ainda
não descobriu que eu sou mas eu vim
falar aqui sobre o que eu não tinha a
menor idéia
muito menos do que eu achava que era
importante que deveria passar pra vocês
e foi dentro desse processo que demorou
quase um mês e meio e eu fui buscar isso
dentro de mim afinal quem sou eu
quem sou eu e foi nessa busca que eu fui
silenciando e fui entrando entrando
entrando e de repente veio uma vozinha
lá dentro dizendo
ana você a coragem pra caramba eu só
coragem mas como assim
e aí na hora que eu falei isso pra mim
mesma quer dizer que nem era eu que
estava falando alguma pessoa uma voz
enfim eu lembrei de um amigo meu dizendo
ana você sabe o que é a coragem eu falei
cara andan lembrei do meu amigo dizendo
coragem vem do corda coração e do hajj
do agir ou seja coragem nada mais é do
que age com o coração
eu falei gente talvez eu seja isso
porque talvez foi agindo com o coração
que me fez estar aqui agora que me fez
fez o vento fazer o vento que me fez ter
coragem de sair da cidade onde tudo
acontece onde é tudo incrível onde você
pode ir sair às cinco da manhã então num
café ou comendo melhor restaurante
mas o que isso me trazer nada pro mundo
eu era perfeita
quer dizer mais ou menos mas dentro da
ana louca maluca
eu ganhava meu dinheiro me relacionava
mas eu entrar na mente eu era um posto
de ansiedade era um posto de insegurança
e muitas vezes um poço de frustração e
eu voltava tudo isso sabe aonde nas
redes sociais
eu olhava as redes sociais e criar uma
relação com ela de autoflagelo
aonde eu olhava aquelas vidas e achava
tudo maravilhoso ea mim era um lixo e eu
ficava lá porque é que eu não consigo
fazer porque que eu não consigo ser mas
sei o quê quem eu era
e aí eu comecei a buscar bom eu quero
verde
eu quero a mata eu quero a natureza
e aí vocês devem falar bom foi aí que
ela chegou aqui ele a bela não se baixam
não eu comprei um papel parede de
floresta e botei na minha sala inteira
porque afinal de contas eu já não saía
mais de casa
eu já achava noite são paulo um saco foi
bom pelo menos eu voltei a floresta que
vou olhar pra ela eu vou vê-la e foi
dentro dessa relação pode parecer até
cômica mas que mudou minha vida porque
foi olhando aquele papel de parede que
eu comecei a perceber o que era fora eo
que ela está dentro e ele inicialmente
me fez mudar dentro porque eu comecei
pra dentro de mim e comecei a ver que na
verdade está tudo aqui dentro
a vida não aquela que os outros colocam
pra você mas sim aquela que você
constrói e você a partir do momento que
você constrói você enxerga e aí você dá
o seu primeiro passo
contato nessa e conecta com o ambiente
ou seja vem de dentro pra fora e aí o
fora a sua ação de traz uma reação
e aí você começa a fazer a roda da vida
que é o que o presente
então é isso que eu acho que é
importante a vida agora e por isso que
me fez vim aqui pra falar isso pra vocês
que me fez chegar numa cidade onde muita
gente dizia que você veio fazer aqui
mesmo
você trabalha com comunicação tinha
filha aqui não tem nada disso não há
ninguém faz isso como não hoje você vê
essa sala aqui cheia repleta de pessoas
tenho amigos meus filmando coisa que
quando cheguei ele a bela falava no
mercado de filme que é isso você tem que
ir pra cidade grande ea gente mostra que
não né
mas eu acho que eu só consegui mostrar
um pouco que não agindo ouvindo meu
coração e com isso tendo coragem né
e as pessoas eu acho que hoje no mundo
elas estão se agredindo muito porque
porque elas não estão ouvindo seu
coração
ou seja discutir o seu coração show
funciona sofra chore porque amanhã você
vai ter secado e aí vai ser uma coisa
nova pra você
só que as pessoas elas têm medo de fazer
isso
elas usam a coragem num outros num outro
lugar né
na coragem na força eu sou forte sou
corajoso
eu falo alto com você isso não é coradi
isso é a agressividade isso a raiva eu
já fui assim aquela pessoa em são paulo
é isso eu pegava minha frustração e pra
eu tentar me sentir viva eu botava em
algum lugar
a raiva é um sentimento delicioso pra
você se sentir viva sem querer está
dentro de você mesmo
então a culpa do mundo a culpa é do
outro ea culpa nunca sua né
então é o que eu vim falar aqui um pouco
é isso assim a gente teve hoje pessoas
incríveis que alimentaram a nossa alma
que alimentar o nosso corpo e que com
certeza vão alimentar nossa vida
então o que eu deixo aqui pra vocês é
fechem o olho
escutem a voz e tenham coragem porque eu
tenho certeza que vocês vão ser muito
mais felizes
obrigada gente